if any videogame fits the definition of
eternal it's Tetris
it was borne out of Russia in 1984 and
was almost immediately embraced by PC
users but once it launched on Nintendo's
wildly popular Gameboy in 1989 Tetris
took off and quickly became a household
name
[Music]
it has since appeared on every console
handheld and practically every other
type of interactive device you can think
of Tetris is the essence of a video game
that's simple to play but difficult to
master it's probably the most
recognizable video game of all time and
his numerous developers have proved over
the years it's also incredibly malleable
[Music]
it's via music Gucci and his team at
enhanced Inc are next in line to make
their mark on tetris legacy their game
Tetris effect has been a project in the
making at least in theory for decades
like so many people music gucci was
enamored with Tetris from the start but
it wasn't a game he carried around in
his pocket it was a costly and addictive
arcade game for the impressionable
college student it was also a game that
would have a ripple effect throughout
his future career in game development
long before he was in control of Tetris
effect you know we put the coins like
like this and play continued and
continued and continued though it's a
game by Sega so that was my first tetris
experience Sega released Tetris into
Japanese arcades in 1988 a mere two
years later music Gucci joined the fold
at sega designing arcade racing games at
a time when the company was pushing the
physical boundaries of man and machine
interactions he's a Gucci meanwhile had
plans of his own in mind I joined to
Sega that was my big motivation
oh I want to create a feel experience I
joined the arcade you know the game
division at the time that was to re but
now
Katy's open so I'm so excited to create
a new type of ik experience before VR
tech caught up with music Gucci's
ambitions he established himself as a
gaming figurehead with the likes of
space channel 5 and res to music centric
games for Sega's Dreamcast the last
console the company would ever produce
space channel 5 has its charms but rez
has magic
it's a sensory meditation wrapped around
an on-rails shooter where your actions
and skills immediately translate into
music
you are the hero but you're also the
rhythm section red cent Mizoguchi on a
path devoted to the pursuit of
synesthesia the perception of images
sounds of physical movements as
connected forces though we now know that
the timing wasn't meant to be shortly
following Reza's success and inspired
Mizuguchi turn to tetris after Reds
production I think it's the 2002 three
so you know the first PSP came out and I
wanted to create a new type of puzzle
game with the res mechanism you know any
sound effects getting the music and the
music react with the visual thing so I
had that kind of a very fuzzy idea and I
tried to talk with Terry's company but
you know they had you know that they
give they gave the license to some
company nothing happened at the time so
but we make new franchising in your IP
like luminous you know it's getting
there luminous but the original you know
I thought oh I want to create the puzzle
with grass experience that was a Tetris
or you know the puzzle sensation
luminous was born at Mesa Gucci's new
studio cue entertainment
once again the harmony of music gameplay
and visuals was practically undeniable
this tack became Hugh entertainments mo
until music Gucci left the company in
2013 one year after his departure
enhanced Inc was born VR devices like
rift vive and psvr were on the horizon
music ooh cheese virtual dreams were
about to become reality you know we made
that
where's infinite right and the same time
same time we did the that kind of
you know people action idea of Tetris
effect but at a time you know not Tetris
effect we call Zant address we started
there know via concept just only you
know the flat screen but we add that
kind of a concept later and we change it
automatically add the particles and the
particles react with the music
[Music]
so you can see the music with PL so that
was a very fresh new you know idea we
add later so but basically is the same
you know new type of storytelling with
that ERISA plan
most of the people you know think what
you add to the game you know let's see
no even if you know black and why a bit
16-bit that was fun and is feel fun so
we had a big you know curiosity and a
creative desire you know we want to
create the new thing so if we could make
to the new experience new storytelling
with truth would be awesome so we had a
big excitement but I was a little bit
nervous but we had experience you know
to create new experience like you know
luminous and that the other games so
yeah we had that confidence we could
make that kind of new thing knowing now
her Nisa Gucci's head was at the time he
developed res it only seems fitting that
his first be our game was res infinite
an enhanced port that includes a new
free flying final stage area X if there
were any doubts about what Mizoguchi had
been chasing throughout his career res
infinite put them to rest and paved the
way for a new body of work that's only
just beginning but unbeknownst to anyone
outside of enhance at the same time
music Gucci and his team began work on
res infinite they were also prototyping
their next game
[Music]
unlike most VR games Tetris effect isn't
designed to directly involve you in the
physical act being portrayed on screen
it's aimed squarely at instilling the
mental Tetris effect that seeps into
your consciousness and influences your
perception after you've watched a few
too many tetriminos tumble into place
and like music Gucci's other games
Tetris effect gets under your skin
almost as soon as you begin playing
having familiarity with tetris means
that the barrier to enjoyment is low and
that you can at least temporarily rely
on rote puzzle-solving while taking in
the virtual atmosphere
and impulsively flip slam and clear rows
of tetriminos as fast as you can
maybe the fundamental gameplay is no
different than a regular game of tetris
but when your entire field of view is
filled with visuals that combine with
music that's in part defined by your
actions Tetris effect lends an entirely
different feel to an incredibly familiar
experience judging by a sampling of a
few modes and a handful of stages it
seems like it really doesn't matter how
you play Tetris effect nor how synthetic
its worlds are it's immediately
enrapturing for Mizuguchi who has seen
the highs and lows of the game firsthand
throughout its years and development
it's the game's own mechanic that sticks
out when he talks about the finished
product this is like II and yen you know
or very good combination you could you
know trigger the zone system it's
getting going to the world and the time
stop and silence and a graphic change
atmosphere change and it's getting all
I'm feeling like in a happiness
and in a zone matrix world
[Music]
all the time I play the song I won't
stay warm
but you know you have time limit so yeah
this is very good combination I'm very
proud of
[Music]
these a Gucci's career is filled with
high note after high note he's proven
time and time again that bridging our
senses and gameplay mechanics can open
up new possibilities for pre-existing
concepts he's been ahead of the curve
all along
and is unsurprisingly looking ahead to
the next generation of VR devices but in
terms of what his next project might be
it's really anyone's guess where it'll
take us next to me and to my team this
is still just the beginning so the
future is of the mixing with many things
and much more resolution and lighter and
thinner maybe it's getting a getting
casual more for everybody so what kind
of content so what kind of game what
kind of entertainment we can create in
the future yeah this is very exciting
is there any one classic game you'd like
to revive I have no idea yet so you have
some idea
[Music]
you